your favorite ice cream flavor this is a
point of contention
you know what mine is I don't because
you have eight billion no no what's the
one that I always want it's traditional
I'm so basic I'm so busy
no vanilla I'm not that basic
this is what I'm talking about you go to
get ice cream with her it's not cookies
and cream it's the other cookies single
flavor it's the other ear this is this
is marriage cookie dough thank you it's
a trigger ice cream Hot Sugar can I say
this for your favorite ice cream flavor
because I don't have one because I don't
care yeah no one was gonna say that
because he doesn't care he goes in and
he goes with whatever his whim is just
whatever it is it's ice cream it all
tastes good getting divorce later